I'm the guy at the Olive Garden. I'm the old man at the Olive Garden family thing
You remember that commercial I do when the grandpa always go
Everybody's like what does he have? What's the condition of the it's only because of my tight frame
You can't see me applauding your impression of the guy
You the ice cream truck drivers, thank you so much ice cream truck drivers
I don't have a new list yet
But we will thank each and every ice cream truck driver by name before this month is over
If you want to be an ice cream truck driver help deliver that ice cream straight to people's ear holes
head over to preaching fun comm preaching fun comm is where you go to sign up to be an ice cream truck driver and
Who knows?
the life you save
May be your own. Oh
Yeah
Here's a show
Hey, Johnny. Do you want to go to an ice cream social?
Yeah, I'd love to great. Let's go
Guys it's my little season
Are you using proper math this time?
Oh
Boy have you started walking already? I have and I'm trying to keep up the thing where I run a little bit
Okay, I'm gonna start running again, and I'm embarrassingly sore from very little running again
Running's not good for you Matt
It's definitely not good for me. I think it's good for other people, but it's not good for me. I don't know
It's probably good for someone. It's hard on the joints, especially men of size
Not that you're a man of my size, but still I'm I don't know. I'm certainly in the plus category
Yeah, but I don't know but still yeah, I can't I I would die if I tried to run at this point
I think well
I was walking the other day and I saw someone running and they were like barely moving like they just simply have their elbows up
And it was like this very it was almost like they were more like tiptoeing than running
Do you know I mean where they just holding their elbows up? No, no, no like
You know, you know, like when you when you know, I don't know I know I'm trying to describe it for the audience
It doesn't help our listeners. It's like this
It's like that ball
Paul is doing me like lazy deep masseuse right now. Just the two sharp elbows. Just I'm very lazy deep masseuse
Lazy deep masseuse. Let me elbow your caboose
Yeah, I do like a nice elbow in my caboose
My elbow slipped in your crack oops
Feet you're not above right? I mean that's what it's all about. Really? That's why I go to the massage parlor
For the possibility of something inadvertently slipping into my crack
It just comes close to cracking use your paw whisper, please
Well, it's it's like a prehensile tail back there. It's just it grabs it whatever might come near. It's like an antlion
Sir let go of my elbow
I can't I can't control it. It has a mind of its own
It's like quado from its prehensile, but I can't control it. That's right
Like moving their arms back and forth like almost like a dance move and they were kind of just shuffling their feet along and
I thought to myself. Well if that counts as running I
Can start running more power walking?
Yeah, yeah
Yeah, if that counts if that counts then I should start going from walking to lazy
lazy running or
Lazy, I can do that power walking is fine
I think the run it's it's the it's the coming down hard and putting the bumps on the joints kind of thing
Well, I was because I was reading an article and they were like, oh, you know like a specific style of power
Walking is in vogue right now out of Japan, which means of course, it's book. Nothing is happening
and
But I simply referenced a mile time of like, you know power walking and like doing a 15-minute mile and I went like gulp
I don't want a mile in 15 minutes the power walked it for 50
15 minute mile per walking walking
Huh, they just pop that out in the area like it was nothing and I was like wait
I'm at like an 18 19 minute mile when I walk I don't walk a 15 minute. So the best is like three minutes, right?
running
Just just the best like nobody's gone faster than like a three minute mile. That's correct
I don't even know if anyone's done a three minute mile
Okay. Yeah, I don't think so. Yeah
If only there was a way I could find out no 3 4 3 13 pondering. What is it three three? What three?
343 point 13 seconds challenge accepted Jacob. Okay
Was that that guy was that Pretoria's with the spring legs was he able is that how he got it?
No, no, they don't set the records with with that. Yeah. Yeah, and then he accidentally trampled his ex-wife
It is a man whose name I'm not going to try to say it starts with a G but he's he's from
Morocco give it a shot Jacob. Give it your best shot
Girl
First of all the barge first syllable Jacob had to take a timeout
G you e rr. Oh you jay el garage
El garage, I think is that it's pronounced Baton Rouge
His Moroccan name means the red stick I actually got a good laugh
I was doing a card trick, you know the Spanish Spanish poetry card trick in San Antonio
I said it San Antonio, of course is French for the red stick
And then I said, oh wait, that's Baton Rouge. It's Spanish for the good land
Nope, that's Milwaukee and I need more of us. I need more of the I need all the translations. Yeah
Oh, yeah, what does that mean? What does the main mean?
The moine it's Spanish for the boy. No, it's it's it's a it's Italian gangster for the moine
Hey, you've got the moine what's a boy, huh?
You don't got mine answering if French is still fine
I'm playing an ignorant. I'm playing an ignorant jerk
All languages are up for grabs right da moine da bears
Well, I just had another zoom meeting with the skit crew
Mm-hmm. I don't know if I said already but steel city improv theater still city improv theater. We are starting a
new
class session
Sadly, I did not get enough registrants in my class for my class session to move forward for the first four weeks
Seems to be a continuing theme in the
Aegis
We gotta get we gotta get you out there doing shows buddy, it's not a just it's not a just it's just a matter of
I'm teaching level one and then we got to get some level ones to get the further thing, you know, so hopefully
In October, we'll get things leveled out
Rich Tellurico is coming out to do a workshop in October. So that'll hopefully help too. We'll see how that all goes
Yeah, but we're just discussing
Getting to know the faculty and yeah, we're gonna hopefully start doing some performances
For the student body and building up something of a community again, you know
Yeah, I don't think you should ever try to start anything. I just happen with the foolers tour
I don't like anything on the East Coast during the first weeks of September is a good idea
I think well transitioning from August
I need I need you and a time machine to come back and have a nice long conversation with Justin a few months ago
I can provide one of those two things you need. Okay, one of the two things great. Okay, it's a time machine
First time foolers tour we were dragging ass and then by October picked up I agree and that's that's seems to be what happened
With my last free class too as I went down to six students from 12 the previous time
Yeah, so it's just it is it's a busy time and it's just a weird time
And August and September is a nasty transition from people doing the summertime things to whatever their fall is gonna be I guess that's true
Whether you do or don't have kids, I think it's just a big transition time
well, hopefully
That'll change up. We'll see speaking of transition
Yesterday and had a little bit of time I
was off and so
She has been desperate to convert a corner of the bedroom
the big the big
bedroom
into a reading nook
Okay, is this for you is she is she trying to encourage you to read she's like my husband can't read no
I'm going to teach him. No, she sees me in bed with a comic every night. I am I am reading
I'm not reading, you know, anything's too profound, but I'm reading a shitload of comic books now
I read almost every night. I read some more Fantastic Four again last night
No, she's uh
What do you think would be the recipes required for a reading nook?
What's the the recipes what do you what do you put in a reading nook? Oh, oh what a chair
Aha
Jacob gets the gold star. That's the big requirement a chair
I play my zoom delay for not tying Jacob. I said what did you say chair as well?
I said come back here specific Matt Matt also said comfy chair. I'll give you a star to Matt comfy chair
Anyway
We went to the one and only value city furniture
down in cranberry
Nothing better for the for the spine than the tailbone like value city furniture. Well
You'd be surprised this chair
you found is
D-lux so she found one that was pretty nice has some you know power
Let go primarily for you or for Anne. This is for Anne, but this is the funny fans look
This is Anne's look, but this is the funny. Okay. She got this one
It's just I all this will do can I get it in this color and they're like, no
Can you not get it in this color you can go fuck yourself now well
Well, it was gonna be like months you specifically know we save this color for special children, right?
Don't you have a lot of this color though? We do we have we so much of you can't get this you can't have this color
This is only for people who have the higher rankings of the Autobot Society and I know that you
Just short of the highest ranking and McPheeters underachiever
Clipboard do not sell to and McPheeters
They got a Polaroid up a man
So she quickly set that chair on fire just to teach them a lesson good about not selling her the chair
No, then the sales lady goes well
Very almost exactly the same price we have the prime model up front. Oh
And I'm like, oh shit and we go up there and
This thing this fucking chair. It's got this thing called. It's the same thing as the other chair had they call it zero
Gravity if you heard about this. Oh, yeah. Yeah gravity get your legs up above your heart
Makes you feel like you're gonna fall the hell down, but they don't but it's all automatic and this fucking chair
Not only does it have zippy zip up and down legs above the heart
it has
Massage in the
lumbar
It has heated seat
It has neck support up be downy. I don't need a heated seat in the house
No, and does and always is she is forever cold. Oh, she's always caught. She's one of those always cold. She's it's got a hidden
drink holder in one arm
the other arm
Holds the master controls
Forget this
the
integrated Bluetooth sound system
This chair is basically a high-fives terrier and
She would never have have gone for this but as soon as she got in it felt how comfy it was
Realized she could get the color she wanted and then started thinking about it
She was actually she said
We were going to buy the thing she said
You know, I was thinking about getting a little
Radio or something to put in the room so that I could do like
Bluetooth stuff to listen to listen to music and stuff and and I was like well now you can just hook it to your
Your chair your chair is basically your
Your stereo your radio. It's all you need
Yeah, and and it can just play stuff even when you're in bed
You can just be listening to your chair and I was like that that radio was gonna cost you probably upwards of $50
This is you're getting this thing for free at this point
So yeah, it was funny but but she gives me guff because I don't know if any of you have experienced this
but going shopping with me I
Will just be like yeah get that. I'll get the better one get the really nice one. Go for that. Oh, yeah, you need that I
I am similar. Yeah, except when it comes to basic technology being included like I don't need my free
Yeah, yeah, I don't get the things like that. I don't have the things like the speakers
I don't like the idea that a program of a washer and dryer for my phone. I don't find them more convenient in any way. I
I would normally agree 100% but the speaker in the chair
Think about this. This is your reading nook
You can just do audiobooks
Right and that's part of it or you can have just soothing music while you're reading and with all the neck paint
I have for putting on headphones and
That's right. I given myself
Well wearing goes that for me
That's true
Like how much nicer would it be to just turn on your side and fall asleep without having to have headphones in or anything?
Now we're getting now we're getting to what you actually want out of this chair
I'm not getting anything out of this chair. Although she was like don't you think something out of this chair?
Don't you think you'll ever fall asleep in this chair? I'm like, yeah, I might fall asleep in this chair someday
But the other thing yeah, she was really concerned about was
She wants it very close to the wall because she got specific measurements for the room, you know
You pardon me I am fighting a terrible cold
She says, you know, I I I want it to kind of hug the wall and the sales lady is like four inches clearance
And she's like what it's like
Four inches away from the wall. It can fully recline
That's it. Oh, yes. Oh, that's that's amazing. Yes. That's yes
Are you think so? But what it does is it like it moves the butt part forward as it does. Yeah
It's incredible. It's an incredible chair
So this is the part of the show that you want to be on zoom or on twitch to see because now you can see the hand
You sit in the chair and just slides down. It just slides. It doesn't recline
Look at Paul and Jacob look like bad breakdancers from the 1980s with their slides
Bad breakdancers, we're as good as that crazy bitch from Australia. Yeah
Is breaking out yeah, oh
I had no idea
Well, each she was so bad. They eliminated breakdancing, huh?
Each host nation can eliminate games and add games
Well, they did it
Well, that doesn't make any sense though cuz the next one's gonna be in LA supposedly right correct
Why in the hell wouldn't you do breaking in LA?
Because no one does that
We don't have competitive breakdancing in this country doesn't bug a little fish still live out there. How about how about who else is out there?
The decision for the 2028 sports that would be at the Los Angeles Olympics was made before
breaking debuted in Paris
So it was not our friend ray gun
Who who got rid of breaking it was already before ray gun dance
So I last got access to the time machine Paul requested earlier. Ah, that's true
You know
it's possible that someone has now invented a time machine because a couple of people have said things to me in the last couple of
Days about going back in time machines to do just silly little tasks like this
So I think I think we're living in the timeline now
Is around and we're just gonna use it for a little for tedious little tasks like this. They're like boogaloo shrimp
Mr. No bones who are some of the other ones turbo? Oh
There were great names. Yeah, the names were amazing. The next there should have been a medal ceremony
Just for the just for breaking names. Yeah. Nah, I'm just I'm sad to break it isn't there. But anyway and getting a
Wonderful chair soon for her reading nook. And so that's coming to fruition
Which I'm super happy for her this nook. What makes it a nook your house already has a nook
It's just a corner of the bedroom that we've we've cleared out
So it used to hold the TV in the bedroom and never watches TV in the bedroom
okay, so we took the TV and the TV stand out to her in-laws and
That's where that lives now, where do you watch TV on your phone? I have it on my phone
Well, I'm usually sleeping in a separate room most of the time
Because my crazy 2 a.m. Wake-up call is a little jarring
so yeah, a little jarring so yeah, so we're switching stuff up with
all that stuff and
Sleep I
Sleep in the guest room right next to her in the reading nook
Okay. Okay. Yeah, and you know, he's gonna be sleeping reading nook in there. I have I've it is the whole thing's a reading
No, you should demand a reading nook in the guest. No, no, no, no, no
Don't even say that no and would be like one two for one climbers
It's it's two twin beds in this guest room and the one twin bread twin twin bed
I sleep in it's made of bread. You told us
It's all bread I do I lay in bed just whoops all bread
Little snack little snack before bed. Oh crusty
Just like pudding skin I've got a I've got a
little side table stacked high with trade paperbacks and comics and
The second twin bed is equally stacked high with trade paper back
Where do you sleep in the bed without the comic books on it? But I also I also it serves another purpose. I
take
giz
To bed with me. Yeah, little lady Elizabeth who is the troublemaker?
She's the old queen who always likes to start shit with the other dogs
So I take her to bed with me so and can get some decent sleep
Some of the time. Yeah
Some of the time
Dog could use a recliner. Yeah, well, that's that's the other thing. That's the other reason that that dog read
She reads at the foot of the bed
With her little with her little she does get a little snacky cake every time she comes to bed
Well, she's got me trained forget about it
I take I get a little biscuit for her if I don't drop a biscuit on the end of that
Biscuits oh man, you joke night biscuits is where it's at and in the morning night biscuits night biscuits
This morning, this is my routine I get up I let giz out
Ted wakes up in her bedroom and he wants out too
So I get everything squared away
I bring giz back into Anne's room and let her snuggle with Anne because she has to keep them separate and
then
After Ted and sometimes Adora goes out Bill hardly ever goes out at 2 in the morning
He's just sleep in the bed. But when they come back, I have to have I get four doggy biscuits
Get everybody back in the room close off the little gate and that's my ritual in the morning and in the more
It's it's it's 2 in the morning and all you hear is
Four dogs crunch are the dogs making any noises my favorite R&B band from the 70s was Otis Doughboy and the night biscuits
Their first single was
Otis Doughboy and the night biscuits
You know who else really likes ASMR dogs eating biscuits and that's the following sponsor magic man. Well as
Masturbatory mucus membranes. Oh god gross Richard Petey
In 2023 that's magical man. Well as
Masturbatory mucus membranes
Hello
I'm
What was my name? The Ken? Well, I know I know man. Well, who's the other guy that led the the the night biscuits? Oh
Otis Otis Doughboy Otis Doughboy. Hi, I'm Otis Doughboy of Otis Doughboy in the night biscuits and
I'm here to sing
big hit
Manwell's
Masturbatory mucus. What was it?
Masturbatory membrane
Mucus Masturbatory mucus membrane great
fantastic
Hey, say it again. Hey biscuits. Hey night biscuits lay down a funky groove
That's right
It's Otis here you can hear my night biscuits, you know, what else you can hear
You can hear it's really hard to do my masturbatory
Mucus membranes
Masturbatory
mucus membranes
In the driving rain of Chicago to the forts of Summertown
all the way to Ohio and the valley down below in the depths of
Milwaukee all the way to Georgia town
Let's go all the way to San Francisco and then go back to Nepal. Yeah
Masturbatory
Mucus membranes because this is definitely a peets. This is definitely a Seeger song and not
Bob Seeger, not even Pete Seeger
Well, I was abandoned by the night biscuits, but that'll happen
You'll have more success with Paul singers silver bullet band
Can't wait to listen
Listen to that book in my in my new nook recliner
Abandoned by the night biscuits a tell-all
Biscuits the the dark side of what's-his-name again?
Boy, Otis, don't know boys the dark side of Otis Doughboy abandoned by the night biscuits
When we come back Otis Doughboy hits rock bottom, I
Kept singing about masturbatory membranes and
The night biscuits were done
next on VH - in front of the music I
Got really really drunk off of
Hefeweizen and
Put the tour bus in a tree
And three three of the night biscuits died on impact I
The other eight just left voluntarily that's right
There were 11 night biscuits
I told you
The show I did where I handed someone my knife for the rope trick and said you believe in the power of the magic wand
And she said I believe in the power of the Lord Jesus Christ, right?
Right a follow-up here. Yeah, I didn't realize I say do you believe in the power and twice in my show?
so oh I
Was doing a show in San Antonio and I had some up to the signature. I believe you believe in the power of your your own signature
And I forgot that I say it the same exact way
And a woman goes why believe in the power of the Lord Jesus Christ for a while?
Wow
Polite applause yeah
And I said, okay, and then we did the whole trick and it worked and everything went great
And then I said really sarcastically well of course every magic I pull off of course is also because of Jesus Christ
and I got a
rousing round of applause
amount of applause
That I like froze like as if I didn't want to be seen by a reptile
Like sure clapping and I literally was like you melted into the background. Don't don't make a move
You can just like buddy. I made a small joke and you reacted like it was a large joke and now you've startled me
No, it wasn't a joke at all. No, and that I was actually giving
Credit for my entire show to the Lord are my Lord and Savior Jesus Christ. They were just they were genuinely applauding
Yeah, yes, they were given credit to Jesus. Yeah. Yes, and then I was fascinated
So awkward that I froze because I was like if I make a move, they'll know
That I I don't that I was being smart. Yeah
The Lord and then they're gonna turn on you like wolves. I was like and if they Google me I'm dead. Oh, yeah
It's good that we don't say godless in the first two words of our podcast description. Yeah, right. Oh shit, we do
You know what's funny Matt are you considering changing your wording now I am
Are you considering changing your religion now both? Yeah, okay good. I mean, I just want to go wherever the money is
Boy, it's the same thing that happens. We're gonna go religion. That's where the money is
It's the same thing that happens with Star Wars fans
when you say may the force be with you and
Then and also with you exactly that becomes the response. It's just turn a phrase
It's just clocked. Yeah, you know, yeah. Yeah, I
Mean that's just dead. Laszlo in the chat says preaching whatever you believe in is the ICS moniker
Which I think is just true
Yeah
Moniker is basically do what you want. I wasn't like angry that it happened
I wasn't like you all just confused you idiots you shape
Good job sheeple and not do that
Are you guys didn't think that trick was too bad
That's right, you're a bunch of sheep let's get him booked in next week
But yeah
But back home from here now through scoop fest, which is exciting good
My dude, I was thinking about leaving right before scoop fest
Carton of milk or a pack of smokes
Yeah, that's it
Hey, I've got a I've got a conundrum. I want to run by you guys. What is that? Oh good
That is conundrums are a specialty
okay, so
I'm scheduled to do my shift tomorrow at the old Tarja and
Then after that I'm not scheduled at all next week. Ah
But I am scheduled the two days before I leave for scoop fest
Okay, so I think they just
Forgot to schedule me for next week. Oh jeez. Now. Here's the thing. You're scheduled in the future past that exactly
Now I asked Dan about this because I did want her opinion and I came back from a managerial standpoint saying
She she schedules people all the time. She said I would probably like someone to bring that to my attention
Just to you know, cuz people make mistakes things happen. Yeah, and it has happened before where I haven't been scheduled and
The bosses are like why isn't Paul here and they're like he's not scheduled
That's kind of like but they discover it on the day right it's like dummies they discover it at 4 a.m
Yeah, when they'd love to have things going their way, right?
so
but I
personally am
cool with just
taking this week as a
zilcher
counting on
the little bit of funds that will probably come in through our
Bucket show right I will I will almost guaranteed make as much at Bucket show as I would
For whatever a couple of days. I'd be doing at the old Tarjay. Oh
You think so do you I guarantee? Yeah, so we already spent your thousand dollars, Paul
You think I make close to a thousand dollars
Anywhere between 15 and 20
Basically a week give or take
There you go. Yeah, good. How many how many days is this gonna be?
It's usually a three or four usually usually three or four
so three and or four
three and or four
You know doesn't like this bit my cat, but let's keep going
Shmoopy hates this and then multiply those hours by diddly and squat as far as my payments
Again, you should be on zoom and twitch Matt. Just showed his very annoying cat camera
He showed the cat annoying annoyed annoyed her head shut up. She was napping. It was like the fuck
Yeah, no, that's straight up. No fun annoying at all annoyed. That's so funny
Okay, go ahead that that sounds like my paycheck right there
But two bucket shows
See that's why I can't that's what I'm counting on I'm counting on that double dip bonus
That and some other little
Things coming in there you always get HJ's out front of it McMullin's so you always got that going for you, right?
Right little walking around money
Yeah. Yeah, my portable
privacy tube
But I take with me officer this is happening with the privacy of this too
Hey, hey buddy, hey, hey come over here. Yeah, what's up? You wanna you want standing a tube and and have me jack you off?
Yeah, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, get my get my tube here. Come on. Come on over here. Great. Let me just
Is this is this marked privacy tube? It is. It's a privacy tube. Yeah
I wrote on the side with a marker. It says
not allowed for search and seizure
Except from the government's that yeah, that makes it legal
In fact, have you see my license plate? It just says I'm not traveling in a work vehicle
Yeah, half of the tube is a modified Gaston flag and instead of a snake. It's a curled penis
Good good. So don't jack on me. Don't bite on me. Don't
What
What's this empty bag of economy 12 pairs of socks? What's this? What's this wrapper from?
That is my XL
Improvised condom that I have to use. I can't magnums don't even work for me
I have to use so much worse than where Matt was going with these old. I have to use old sock bags
You know you think I could use like
Grocery bags, I can't
The grocery bags don't have the plastic doesn't have enough rigidity to maintain
But yeah, I always complain about my condoms. It's not enough rigidity old
12 to 14 pack sock bags are my condom of choice and honestly
They only cover about half of what I got going on down there. Yeah
girth and
Circumference wise both
Deal yeah deal is right. Yeah, no search and seizure
So for Canadian scoops out there in October, yeah land in st. John twice
Once with princess and once with Virgin
Okay, and I'm also gonna go to
Boston and
Charleston, South Carolina on Virgin
And so maybe we can do some kind of scoop meetup situation there
Interestingly enough. I'm going to like Eastport, Maine is a big cruise stop on the Canadian circuit. Huh? I was like, oh cool
I have a bunch of old friends. I haven't talked to in Portland, Maine in a long time, man
Large state turns out pretty big. Yeah. Yeah
That's the same thing with the Pennsylvania. It's crazy. Like you can't really it's four hours from Portland, Maine. Yeah
It's not a lunch
It's not a meetup for coffee kind of situate. Yeah, so
I'm actually closer to most it's like that's only two hours from Boston
But even that's like not please don't travel two hours to have a cup of coffee with me. I don't think that's worth it. Yeah
Yeah, although any excuse to get out of Boston
I should go there. You're right. I should get out and go there. Oh
No, I meant the people who are in Boston probably want to get out for an hour or two
Just give them the excuse. Let's get away from that smell of beans
Oh so many beans. It's all baked beans out there. That's what crack the Liberty Bell. I went to
all them beans
They're beans though
My my scoop fantasy football name is I say horse you say beans and
I'm not happy with any part of that
Start we've already lost our first game that would be an amazing chant to get going at Churchill Downs
Magic I'm in a magic magicians fantasy football league and
Do you want to see another card trick is my name and
That actually won that Devante see another card trick, but I lost to scoop Justin
Jelenic I lost to him by seven points. He's the Fighting Squirrels. No, I like the Fighting Squirrels. Yeah
I'm trying to find mine here. Oh, here we go. I think I won my I think I won my game this year
Matt Hasselbeck that ass up
We have oh I did I beat a little Lebowski we
Have a but choke on these nuts, which is pretty good little about good
Slytherin Scott
Jenna sake one, which is nice. Oh, but choke it choke on to check out these nuts is my opponent this week
Are you gonna say Kwan? That's pretty funny. Tyreek of alcohol is a cold over from last year. It's a great name
Yeah, that's a solid one
arsonists get all the TVs
mint chip
Sammy's sneaky team and CDs nuts
Okay, so we've a classic a lot of a lot of a lot of a lot of nuts and beans in the scoop league this year
We're funny, but not original but fuck you for beating me Justin. Okay, fuck you pal. Ah
This is great, you know who else beat Matt this weekend, it's the following sponsor today's show is brought to you
Batman's home for retired super villains. That's from Matt aka Stormageddon in 2024
That's Batman's home for retired super villains
Hello. I am the night. You may know me as Batman. I
Know that you're old. I know that you're tired. I know you're sick of putting up fighting me
Now it's time to have you retire
Come on to Batman's home for retired super villains. I had a nice self bed waiting for you and I promise no guns
No guns
Go ahead lay down rest sleep if you can
Close your eyes if you dare. I'll be watching. I'll be waiting. I'll be breathing. I'll be sleeping
I'll be storing hanging from the roof waiting for you to make a move
Oswald Cobblepot, I've got a room just for you
I keep the thermostat set to 30
It's perfect
Do I Oh
somebody's here
Hello
My god, it's the eight remaining night biscuits I
Thought I defeated you in that bus accident. That was no accident. That was me driving you off the road
with a batarang I
Tried to kill all of you, but only succeeded in killing three
I can't resist the funk
We're we need a place to stay we left Otis, okay
I've got a nice room for you here. It smells really funky. Oh
Covered in comic books, don't ask questions, you know what I just do
I
Went to the the Westgate this week, they had the big blues bender. Oh the Westgate resort this week
You know that used to be the Hilton where they use to have
The what did you ever see that? Oh
God, I just got a flurry of stuff in my messages because
September 8th is the anniversary of the closing
So a lot I thought I felt just good that day. Oh
Just woke up feeling happy
No
Star Trek the experience around him sort of a bitch. So what was that the Westgate this time?
The big blues bender the the big blues festival that happens in Vegas every year. It's happened at the Westgate for a few years
But it's a it's a huge blues festival
They do I think it's either three or four days and it's like noon to 3 a.m
Every day. Well, it is this all held in that of Elvis theater. Is that where it all is?
Well, that's one of the rooms so it they've got the Elvis theater. They've got another huge theater set up in the convention area
They've got an outdoor stage. They use the the lobby stage and they have the the shimmer cabaret
Or I don't know if it might be called something different now, but that that theater that's in there as well
So they have five different spaces. Oh, yeah, the shimmer cabaret former home of menopause the musical
Quite a few different things have been in the shipper. Yeah, I saw
Sacred halls sacred hall. I saw Gilbert Gottfried performed several times in the shipper cabaret. I thought Gilbert the shimmer and it was awesome
It was Gilbert in that room was so good. That is that such a good room
It's a nice intimate space stand up is great. Oh, it's so good
I saw I was in the I was in the Westgate for this this big blues festival
We were we were outside some friends came in town in conjunction with this
And they were getting married in Las Vegas. So we were we were hanging out with some friends that had just gotten married
We had some family in town. They were they were hanging out the blues bender. So we were we were there
we're watching music and I say I
Need to go to the restroom. So I excused myself and go to the restroom there in the Westgate Resort and
I'm standing there at the urinal guy comes up to me at the urinal
Oh, he starts peeing old older guy old guy at the urinal. He comes up and
Just lets out the biggest fart
You have ever heard in your life
In a pseudo public space, do you think it was prehensile back there was he trying to grab it was
I don't think I don't think there was any control happening back there at all that explains the symbol crashes
That's the loose caboose the symbol crash
I was out there rocking a zildjian with his hinder
He almost fucking got it too because I was real close
Turning and vomiting right?
This guy is gonna make me fucking yeah, what is she's yelled you got a bell? Oh, no, it's smelled
It was the worst thing that's happened to me in a month
Bad bathroom luck the scoops are commenting you have this is my second
This is my second urinal story on this podcast 12 years. Come on, but but still no no
I was jacking it was yeah
Yeah, that was more than weeks ago
I just thought you were you weren't counting that as a bad story
I've had one bad bathroom experience
The other one I took as a compliment
I was like this is I just looked at him. I was like what the
What are you doing? And he just oblivious of course fucking oblivion of course
I mean, I really thought I was gonna yak on him, but that is it was that is the really hard do it
Sure, no, no if you're gonna rip one the bathroom is the is the most appropriate place
But it is tough here in that close of proximity
Also the Westgate bathroom that I was in I didn't I didn't properly explain the layout of the restroom
What is the Westgate to you? Was this the one inside the old space quest?
It's the one next to it. It's one right next to the old space quest
It was not the one inside space quest not the one inside now the futuristic urinals. No, no, not all that
Do they still talk? I?
Don't know when you used to ask Jacob when he definitely specified
He did not go into the bathroom you just described just ask him facts about the bathroom
We didn't go I sure did I sure did Matt because it's me precisely what happened
I'm going I'm going into the space bathroom
Even if I don't have to go space bathroom space bathroom
I'm gonna go revisit it that guy was trying to get there, but as he was jet propelled in
You know if he'd done that in the void of space that could have propelled him infinitely towards the outer rims. Oh, yeah
Yeah, yeah. Yeah. No, he's basically warp speeding right through that bathroom
Oh, but the but the urinals you would piss in them and
It was dumb because we were right next to the Star Trek experience, and it wasn't it wasn't you know
They were like, let's spacey theme it
But when you pissed in it, it would go
detecting luck levels
And it was like yeah, it would go detecting levels. Yeah
L-U-C-K luck levels and now it's very similar now. It just says detecting hepatitis is what it says. Yes. Yeah
We are so sorry. You got you got hep C. Oh
bad luck
And then then when you when you left when you were giving it the old the old shake
It would go may the look be with you
It's better way the fuck is the lock exactly may the force be with you was may the luck be with you
And I was like first of all
wrong space thing
Yeah, it should have done, you know should have done other stuff should have been like luck long and prosper
The only difference now Paul is Las Vegas offers that urinal, but it says would you like an enhanced urinal experience pay six dollars?
Oh, oh and then does the Borg head come out
Jake you were there does the Borg head come in?
After I ate one of the hot dogs I worked there
started peeking out I
Would pay six dollars to have the 4d Borg head pop out
Give me
Just so our listeners are clear because some people some people you know, some people watch us on zoom
Some people watch us on twitch some people watch us on YouTube some people just listen to this as an audio experience
It's for those people. I want to make it very clear that what Paul wants specifically is he wants to stand
urinating at a urinal and then have the head of a Borg alien come out and
Felaciate him felicitate urinal felaciate
They will blast you with the felicitate or resistance is futile we're getting through the shields captain
We're almost to the balls
Think about space baseball think about space baseball think about space baseball. Oh, no
There is such a thing on DS 9 the Niners
Cisco was a baseball fan and he would play games of baseball in the holiday
I thought you meant there was a toilet that would suck you off as you were peeing
what I
Thought that was really weird thing to have on this Star Trek show, but there is one in Japan
That's true standards and practices fell asleep at the wheel does
Does the thing in the in the space shuttle can't you know what this is on me guys?
I I was the one in charge of checking this episode
That we were what if we were in the in the guardrails, I mean
I I fucked this up you'd be pretty close if you put if you if you tape some googly eyes to that space shuttle one
You'd be pretty close
right
Yes, sorry
I know just getting off just just laying out the argument. Go ahead. Keep going
Okay, it's gonna take a lot to craft
Molded pork head and then incorporate it with a sucky offy thing
Sure, but if you've already got the space shuttle one that goes on your Hoover to our English listeners
The philatator is a real thing in the space shuttle, right?
What do you mean Destro you've lost
I
Tried to tell you Cobra commander someone came in the middle of the night and stole the philatator
Snake eyes
It could have been I doubt it though. He's a ninja. He doesn't have a need for a philatator
It was probably no. No, it was it was me. Actually. I I definitely had that need for the philatator
That's that's it's me. Oh snake eyes. I got it. It's fine. Now you talk now. I do. Yes
This is this is the reason I haven't talked up until now is this is what I sound you were blocked up. I see, okay
Yeah, I'm just a little stopped up. I am so glad that we could help you out. Mr. Snake eyes
Thank you. Thank you. Oh
Cobra commander you are an ignorant poppin. J
What you heard me?
However, my what still stands you my one is not because the words themselves
You ignorant poppin J
That was popular TV writers didn't have the internet so they had a that was back when every TV writer was still 70
That's what's going on and and had a thesaurus. Yes
Yep, the source from 1962
Yeah, I believe it means like someone just obsessed with their appearance and very preening and prissy
That's what a poppin J is. Well, thank you. I appreciate that Paul. Yep night biscuits of the philatator says scooper Nova girl
I think you have a philatator on the night biscuits. Oh
Yeah to lady 80 are on the night biscuits not too it's not too late
It's not too late to get your scoop costume to get there to be a urinal sprung boar head
If somebody comes to the fucking costume ball as a urinal with a boar head on it
my fucking shit, I
mean
That's a contender right there. I've had a few scoops write me to be like, hey, is anyone ever dressed like this?
And I'm just laughing. I'm like, nope
We got some wild shit coming this time it's been a pretty it's been a pretty rich meaty vein of
ridiculous characters
I
I'm dressing up. This is the fart that Jacob described. That's what I'm dressing
I will vomit on you. I
Will just vomit on you. I think I need to be the Borg head urinal equip
That's crazy. I don't know
All right, Jacob do you have a scoop mail? Yeah, we do let's do some scoop mail
Message for you
We got a scoop mail from monod knock scoop in episode 1240 Paul talked about anime and manga and
Referenced go which he claimed is what we would call Othello
Go is not Othello
Othello and reverse II are similar but go is completely different go is said to have been created at least two
Hundred years ago and we have evidence of it from around 500 BC
Reverse II was only invented in 1883 and Othello was in 1971
I could go on but I'll just stop here and say that Paul was wrong on this one. That's what not not scoop
I was close. You can look it up. It's close. I
Agree Paul that you were close. I won't take the I won't take the full L
Thank you rain. We're in chance that you were for me in the comment. You were really edging on that one. No, it's not that far off
It's not I mean, there's a I think there's a difference in size of the board and that kind of thing
But it's not right size of the board. Yeah. Yeah
Motion of the ocean and whatnot. Oh, no ranch has not sticking up for me. No, it's not
You walk alone I
Do walk I walk alone full journey walk alone into the urinal with the Borg head on it
Paul just took a full journey there
Me I don't have people supporting. I have no one no one in my corner on this one
But it's better because I'm alone with my Borg head. So that's what we got one for mom and a scoop
It finally happened. Oh, it has been a few years of trying to obelisk my fiance
But it was Paul's hot dog story in
1241 which did the trip. I did it. Yes
conversion hey, hey
My hubby my hubby to be looked right at me straight-faced and said if you can
Microwave it then that's what I'll do. I
Naively thought about listening to the podcast together was the new part of our love story
But now I only see it as grounds for canceling the wedding
My future ex-husband then told me that during his bachelor days
He would microwave three hot dogs and eat them with bread as a special treat
His favorite though was to microwave the raw
Crumbed chicken patties and then put them in between two pieces of buttered white
home brand bread the super cheap stuff and
Would put some shredded lettuce in if he was feeling fancy
Now now I can recreate that fart for Jacob I
Would like to add here that this time he was having his
Delicacy he was making very good money. So this was a choice. Yes
It's a choice. It's a great choice before wrapping the hot dog
You would dip the bread in the Lord and let it absorb it like a fun. Oh
I am 150% on this guy's side. I
Read this out to the visionary chef to make sure that he was
Comfortable with me sharing this and he wanted me to add that if he was feeling ultra fancy
He would add in some shredded cheese some pre shredded cheese specifically when question about the kind of cheese
He said I don't know the cheapest one
Fuck you all in the faces, but only after I've heavily disinfected it. That's the ominous scoop. Boom ominous scoop
I'm so happy for you. You have found a keeper
This man knows what's up on the culinary tip for real for real
Oh, I like that. That's fantastic. I love me a breaded chicken patty
To this date to this day Mike, but a microwave of course
No, I don't want crisp I want I want it to be rubbery
You are a monster, no, I'm not I just was raised on garbage food
Climbing you guys gonna have a microwave built into the right by the right by the thigh that new recliner
I'm gonna hook up into the Bluetooth. It's gonna go get out of the chair you chicken brisket filled bitch
You if you bring one more hot dog to this chair, I'm gonna come alive and eat you
No, I'm not gonna use that chair very often
Dedicated games and twitch says that they don't care if they're not married yet. It's time for a divorce
I agree. No, I agree. You have found the one
You have found the one that's it now. I had three microwave hot dogs for lunch today. I'll have you know, what that's what I had
Chaotic don't sometimes the universe sends you signs before you marry a person and this scoop has smashed their face on this sign and
Still didn't notice it. Let me tell you. Yeah. Yeah. No the signs. They're the right signs
The signs are go move forward and enjoy
That's not a science
Versus right now. I microwave three hot dogs today and
The one in the center was the only one that still retained its hot dog essence the other two
Became very much
You know
Burn unit victims, but but there was still fine. So fine. Well, how long do you microwave a hot dog for?
I usually go for about 45 seconds per dog. I'm a minute a minute for two and
It was three. So I went 130
Okay, it was a little too long
But and you say the the side ones the two on the outside on the outside
They came a little well done. They came in a little hot at the center one was pretty much perfect
So your microwave three hot dogs you had one that was better than the other two, but you still ate all three
Do you own a toaster oven?
don't
Okay
patreon.com/a scoops
Honestly, the problem is we don't have any space in our fucking kitchen our kitchen is so small. It's like a Nats
It's like a Nats ass so it is so small
It's so small that when I'm in it and can't be in it and vice versa and we often get angry at each other if we're
Both trying to be in the kitchen at the same time
It's so small if you have one of the utensil drawers open you can't open the refrigerator
That's the fucking truth one more one more. It's so small that it's so small that
If it's a cold night, you can just go ahead and turn on the oven and that's gonna heat the whole kitchen
Not a joke just a fact, you know, what happens is the same company that makes that recliner it makes refrigerators
So when you only need four inches from the wall and the whole fridge is true lay out on the bottom for you
You could recline on the refrigerator
My kitchen is so small that Bilbo Baggins was like the fuck am I supposed to do to cook in here?
My kitchen is so small that a Smurf came up in that bitch and was like this some fucking bullshit
I need room. I
Mean I really don't know I'm back to the I'm back to the chicken patty
I'm back to the breaded chicken patty. What what's the problem with the breaded chicken patty getting microwaved?
It's just gonna be mushy. It's gonna be it's gonna have a little mush to it
But the trick is you do it half and half
Do it you flip it half and half you do it with 30 and you flip it for 30 flip it and then it's okay
But it's not gonna be crispy or anything
Well, if you do that, it's still gonna be mushy if you do it one side full-on. It's gonna be runny
Do one side full-on, okay, but if you do that, you'll be all right. Yeah. Yeah. I
Grew up on that shit, man. That was the I have not seen a single person in either chat defend
Microwave chicken patties. Look, I'm not looking for defenders
I'm just looking for like-minded individuals who are into freedom and taste
You have another ranch and just points out the oven yeah
Winter scoop winter scoop defends you quiet winter scoop. Thank you. I'll tell you the oven like I said, it's a it's a damn
Gas oven so it takes forever in a day to heat up and then once it's hot it's hot and our house
It just heats up the upstairs really bad on a hot day. Yeah, so it's not something we want to use
Wrap the hot dog in a paper towel. What are you talking about ranch slunk?
You're gonna get all kind of fibers in it
Yeah, that's the problem. That's
That's my bits of paper towel my concern is bits of paper towel
I know what kind of paper towels you buy that are just disintegrating in microwaves. I'm gonna get you a brulee target brand
That's what I get you for your birthday Paul. What are you gonna get a brulee torch?
So I could just like brulee my my hot dogs over the torch a hot dog over the sink
you just put it on a stick and just
You know what? I would actually really love but I I think it would just I know it would go on it would end my marriage I
Would love to have a 7-eleven roller
So I just life any time like that that has respect for the the cooking the outside in
But nature of how how but can you imagine designed for but it would end my marriage?
The house would always smell of hot dog
No, I don't know what in your marriage ball or the yeah, the glass dome will do it. That'll keep it the smell contained
But but also I now see I'm sitting here thinking of mine nook
I can get those planner you can't get a hot dog. I could get those I think
Time Paul, this is this is the time in in a married couples life
We're one of the one of the couple wants a thing and this is your opportunity to be like look
I have always hated reading nooks, but I'm letting you have a reading no
You have always hated 7-eleven hot dog rollers
But you could let me have my 7-eleven hot dog roller honestly little of the living room in the house honestly
I'm the one who would not like the 7-eleven hot dog roller in the house because it would be too much of a headache to clean
Up. I'm gonna get you one of those
Trask areas all those beat skewers spears for outside. Yeah, the giant meat rack for outside
Oh god, I want to track any animals at all
And Teddy Teddy is on rabbit number five this season
He ate a bird the other day
It just doesn't end with that guy and heaven forbid. I have hot dog rollers going out there
The animal kingdom would come for me at some point
That's not like I like the idea of you outside defending your meat skewers
Like a night like a gladiator there is no defending those meat skewers
And you're not supposed to clean the hot dog rollers it ruins the flavor says Scoob Jesus
I think you're probably right now. I don't I don't want anything to do with that device
Honestly, yeah, cuz you just want to keep on
Microwaving your hot dogs. The reason I microwave is for ease and
Convenience the hot dog roller is not easy or convenient
Listen unless I go to the convenience store where someone else's trick is getting your own bacho cheese
I
Is I know you don't have room for toaster oven, but I'm just saying in the event that maybe you you find one
Okay, we used to have one at the old place finishing a microwaved item in the toaster
Gets back the crisp. Yeah. Yeah, if that's if that's what you're looking for
You have to be looking for that Paul
Paul I need you to look for that
As a friend as a friend no, thanks
Come to scoop fest. It'll be at the end of September
Come watch Matt and Paul finally settle this grudge match style
We're gonna have a taste test contest of chicken patties. We both have five minutes to cook it. Oh
I got you licked man
Done in 250. I I get things done just as bad. I cook for children all the time
Okay, so I can cook for you because I cook for my kids. You do the air fryer thing
Yeah, exactly. I have an air fryer air fryer solid and we used to have an air fryer, too
Yeah, yeah air fryer. She took a lot of room. It's an awkward. That's true. That's the only that's it, man
We got a spot for our dishes. I wash the dishes in the sink. Ah
Do you have
ambitious
My brother my brother. Could you do a top mounted toaster oven hanging hanging right below a cabinet?
No, we have that with the microwave. It's about it's above the oven already and there's no there's no other space
You don't have any other can you in the kitchen because you're not turning on the oven
Could you put the toaster oven in the case you put it inside the oven?
Listen think my it'd be so well insulated. I think I've told you guys
Just yeah, just let it melt into the oven that'd be fine
You never turn it on that oven let's just call that a loss
No, we use the oven
Okay, ah and we we the royals we uses the oven. I use the oven
To hold things. No, I use it to cook
Fair enough
We forgot about the frozen pizza. Oh, I you know what I did. You know what I did. This is my this is on me
I take full responsibility on this one
that makes one I
got a
fresh
Pizza from Walmart the other day
Okay, not throw
Okay, so they they they put it like like Papa Murphy's they prepare a
A pizza doughed thing that you just buy and put in the oven put in the oven for a few less minutes and good to go
Right. It was so nasty
Whole thing the Walmart ready to bake pizza. Yep was not the best pizza you've had I
Didn't say it was not the best pizza. I had it might have been one of the worst pizzas
I've ever had like this podcast. We have a history of very terrible pizza. Are you sure that's right?
It really reminded me of that trunk pizza vibe
Especially especially with the the herbs whatever herbs they put on that shit. I heard herbs, you know
Aromatics, you know, they're covering up. They're covering up bullshit is what's going on. Yeah, Paul likes the aromatics of a nice sausage
I like the aromatics of Chuckie fucking cheese pizza. Like I don't give a damn. Give me cheese plain simple
Yeah, he says over he says this podcast in quotes you Matt. It was you, right?
But if Paul can say we use the oven then I can say this podcast
I use the oven for french fries. I make french fries in there sometimes. Oh
Do you have
Stone or pizza or like one of those special pans? No. Oh, I have a guess I go right on the rack
Haven't got some Paul has a pizza stone. This is not look. I'm not a Walmart defender
But the pizza stone makes a difference
Definitely you can get this pans. Do you put it on top of it?
No, what happens is so that so that you get because the truth is if you're to make pizza at home
They say the key is to just bake the dough first and then add the pizza toppings in the second phase and put it back
In the oven, right?
Interesting you get that that gives you the best pizza crust quality for an at-home pizza
But if you're talking to make your own crust, no, no, I'm saying I'm just letting you know the logic here
I'm asking how do I get this crust that is separate from ingredients that I then cook first
You can buy like a pizza dough. You can buy like a like a like a Bertolli that's already cooked up
No, no, no, no, not one of those like like a canned pizza dough a
Canned pizza dough or like a but like I could preformed but a raw pizza dough raw pizza dough
Yeah, you need to be raw. It can't be the pre the pre-cooked Bertolli or however you say that one. All right
And then at home if some people want to make their own pizza dough, which you're not gonna do
But we don't have to worry about that
But then you you you you basically do around where you cook in the oven on its own as if it's a loaf of bread
Like a fright of a bread you just bake it and then you go ahead and add and add it before it's fully
With you you add your okay. I'll just put it back in and that's what gives you the best
Pizza now to circumvent that there's this pan
That has like almost like a screen on top of it's like a metal on the bottom and like a metal screen on the top
it's like a two layered pan and
You can buy that and you put that pizza that you bought
On there and that screen allows the oven to cook the bottom of the pizza crust really well
While you I could show it to you, but it doesn't help our list. Well, I mean I put it right on the rack
I don't I don't put anything in between it. We should
Okay, you should all right cool
Just think about it. Yeah. Yeah, no the pizzas the pizza stone just helps like it distributes the heat and all like no
I'm sure I'm sure it's better. I'm sure it's better. But honestly, it was just
The toppings it was a pepperoni pie and it was just not good
Yeah, I mean I'm definitely like clocking out I'm done defending Walmart pizza right now you
Know that maybe was an upset that could help you but I'm also fine with you calling it a loss for the rest. Yeah, I'm yeah, I'm out
I'm out. I'm out. I'm gone. I'm gone
Yeah. All right. There's a pizza buddy. I see. Okay pizza dough. All right. Okay got it
Sorry, I'm sending an email here
Oh
Hot dogs and microwaves. Yeah
Hello Jim Cruz and scoop here from Delaware. I feel the need to apologize
publicly to Matt Donnelly for wreaking havoc by passing along rumors that
Spellbound on Princess Cruises was shutting down as it turns out princess is simply revamping the experience
So is not to include dinner and will now be a cocktail speakeasy experience with a magic headliner act Matt
Matt, do you know anything about this or do you know anything about the apology?
I brought this up on Africa babble and not here
But Chris is a listener of both and he wrote me saying I don't know what the hell this is about and I panicked and wrote
My agent being like hey
Fuck and spread my availability out if this is gonna fuck up my dates that I have in princess
Like let's look around and my agent basically wrote me back being like
Chill out chill
Like no when they say they're revamping it's the experience of September it's because they're revamping the experience of September
Everything's fine, buddy
Everything's fine. Andy cheek just put a picture in the chat Paul the pan I'm talking about. Oh, okay. Oh, I see now
Okay, cool. All right. I'll look about getting one of those
Yeah, my wife and I will be on board the brand new star princess on February the 14th
2025 this is I guess from the past
And I will be checking out the spellbound venue that if any scoops would want to go with us, but there's all the stuff
Yeah, oh, they have a web. They have a website though. We've talked about this before go with Lisa
Comm my wife owns the travel agency and as a bonus for any scoops
We will happily provide you with some onboard credit to defray a pretty potentially our right cover
The cost of checking out spellbound as a consolation to the boys
I humbly offer you a price is scryte that I created three years ago and never made it to air
I'm excited to hear the questions since I have no idea what they are cruise and scoop. That's aka Chris
So just real quick over here. Just just to people if people want to go through that website, I'll be on the brilliant lady
Is the name of the virgin ship?
right October 4th through the 16th and then I will be
on
the star princess the fifth November 15th 22nd and the Sun Princess the 30th through the 7th
And then I'll be doing more dates and the following year, but those are those are the big cruises
I'm doing for the end of the year
Very cool. Let's do a little price of scribe from cruise and scoop here question one in
2016 mean the clam broke the Guinness record for the oldest animal in the world
What was means estimated age in years Matt? You're up first. This is price of scribe
Go over you lose to the closest answer without going over
212 being
to 12 my name is
Jacob I
The clam Wow, I
Was the oldest animal though, so yeah, he's got to be real old so let's go to our 270 Paul
Well, I know there's like that Galapagos turtle. That was right at 300. How's that right? Yeah, I'll go
Hey, that's what I give a third position that's true Paul gets a point
707 yes, I'm saying say it's it's gotta be a hundred seven. Wow, uh
a
Kenksha. Yeah, they killed Ming to age. It says winter scoop. Of course they did. This is the life we live
Oh, yeah. Yeah, I do remember that I vaguely remember that god damn it. This is oh
stupid shit
It's okay Paul. No, it's not it is. No, I'm sad. I know but it's still okay. No
Long locks have earned her a place in the Limca Book of World Records
Limca Book of World Records
2020 through 2022 and is also in the India Book of Records. How long in inches is her hair?
All right
So where's my phone?
You can't use your phone. I can use a calculator. No, you can't use a calculator. I said no calculators. Where did it say?
We said no calculators years ago. Oh
Right. It's the right next to the air fryer. It says no calculators. That's right. Look at the air fryer Paul
It's right there. Okay
Let's see. So
48 50 60
72 let's let's go an even hundred. I'll go an even hundred inches. That's a guess. I will go
130 130 map
one
Wow, yeah, I think you're both over
Jacob gets a point a hundred nineteen. Wow. Nice one Jacob a hundred nineteen inches
Paul got bit by the Price is Right rules, buddy. I did good. That's fair
Question three every time you shuffle a deck of cards
Chances are that you have put them in an order that has never been seen in the history of the universe
The total number of possible ways the deck could be arranged
Ends up being eight followed by how many more digits?
Paul you're up first
Is it
Quatrillion
Something like that. Yeah, I believe it is something like that. Yes
Uh, I will go 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 30 40 15 6 and 18 18
18 Matt
You know where I'm doing 20
Jacob gets a point 67. Oh come on boogaloo boogaloo 67 we were off by an order of magnitude
And then some
67 maybe 40 40 magnitudes. Yeah. Wow
Let's see Las Vegas is known for taking the essence of other destinations
Reproducing it and making it as spectacular as the original with its own unique Las Vegas spin how?
How tall in feet is the Las Vegas Eiffel Tower? I?
Don't know how many feet I got into her
Your honor
Matt you're up first
1400 1400 I
Mean that seems I don't know it seems believable. It seems like a perfectly good amount of feet. Oh, that's the tower could be we know feet
That seems like a lot of feet though. I'm gonna say a thousand feet
1400 is way too many feet Paul
420 represent both would it be?
Paul gets a point. Yeah, I didn't want to go too high for 20 represent
Glad we've got Paul Mattingly here representing drug culture, right?
What he told me in u.s. Dollars of a Taylor ham sandwich from Tierney's Tavern in Montclair
New Jersey menu accessed on July 18th 2022. Oh Matt
This is way up from when you were a young lad servant. Oh inflation inflation. Yeah
Yeah, I should on salted weird pork product that you slide. I have deli meat
On a cooking show the other day they were making a
Taylor ham sandwich, they were doing a good Jersey bit making a Taylor ham sandwich. Yeah. Oh my god
It looked horrible and I still wanted it
It looked salty on as they were slicing it and putting it in the pan it looked salty somehow
These are all designed to get people to drink right everything served in these certainly. Yeah, certainly
I mean, I think it was designed to survive the Great Depression as well. Well that too. Well, yeah. Well, it's coming back, baby. Let's go
Let's go
Let's see. So I think the price is
This is Tierney's in 2022. I think the price is six dollars and 38 cents
Paul
Jersey money doesn't go as far
That is true
And plus not compared to the metropolis of
Pittsburgh they're not gonna have a lot of change on the in this cuz it gets thrown at him
Overgoes guessing 1399. What do you get like a party sub?
I'm gonna go
Five eighty six
five eighty six
I was going to say six dollars, but then you guys are right in that range
Well, but there's there's room. There's you can squeeze right in there. It's dollars. Yep. Yeah
Here's the things we really get a Taylor ham sandwich
He's gonna tell her him and cheese sandwich, but he's this Taylor ham sandwich, which means you ah, you'd add whatever
50 cents for cheese
Don't remember those days when it was just 50 cents for added cheese
Here's the really hard part attorneys we just charged whatever we never got corrected and so
It was like once a year I'd look at the menu bag. Oh really
Possible that Matt has never known what this cost
the Taylor Swift ham sandwich it speeds right through you
I'll split the difference. I'll go six bucks six bucks
Matt was exactly right look at you Matt and you know what? That's how it should have been
That's that's how that question the man the man worked there. He should get it exactly right
That's I'm actually impressed that Paul and I were as close as we were well
You know what though? I should have trusted my gut and I should have said six because I was right
They don't want to put any change in it cuz they don't want to get that fucking shit
What change thrown at him they got to make everything even dollars
Yeah, just doing it for their own safety. Yeah, I mean they could still get pelted by some sack of joe is but ain't nobody
don't knows
Steven Spielberg once stated in an interview that ET was a plant like creature and neither male nor female
According to the film's novelization ET is over. How many million years old Paul 40?
40 Matt 40 million
Sure, no, I don't fucking know
Matt you were just talking about the 18
Civilization the other day. What did it say that? Oh, yeah. Yeah, two two million two million
Three million look at this
Jacob gets a point ten million damn had million years old
Over the course of her nearly 70 year reign Queen Elizabeth has seen more thing. Oh, this is before she died
Queen Elizabeth has seen more than a few regime changes in American politics
How many u.s. Presidents has the Queen met in person during her reign?
Matt you're up first. Oh
For nearly 70 year reign how many presidents has she met
I'm gonna go with
Five
Let's see I
She met Kennedy
She met Trump so that's two
Boy Matt thinks five, I mean he must be able to count more than just Kennedy and Trump then
How much five presidents are you saying she met Matt? I don't know. I'm just guessing
There's there's Grover Cleveland. There's Taft
I think she met FDR. I bet you me. Yeah, I was wondering about so yeah, I would think she I would think she must have over
She became years of being very early in her life. Oh, sure. I would say Obama and Reagan. I think so
Yeah, I can see George W getting a visit. I just average it out to two presidents per decade
All right
Yeah, I don't know let's say seven Paul eight
Oh
Paul gets a point 13. That's what's gonna be my guess but I didn't want to go too high
Represents too many presidents too many presidents. Yeah, it is Matt. How many presidents have you met me one, unfortunately?
Was in the room with Clinton
Yeah, I think it's a meet him. Yeah, he Parliament. I
Mean, I'm a parliament funkadelic. I'm at Bootsy Collins. Mm-hmm. Good. That's all that's all I'd care about
hospitality to very private
He didn't want to go in the tube when I met him, you know, that was that was when Clinton was touring with the night biscuits
That's right. Good good old days. Okay
I lost three three two. So I well officially so far we haven't gotten to the bonus round yet
How many points would you like to wager out of your two points? I like to wager two of my points and I'd like to
Go at a medium pace at a medium pace. Here it goes
Wheel of morality turn turn turn. Tell us the lesson that we should learn and Matt gets an extra four points Wow
Matt is crushing it
Matt leaps into the lead with six points. I have to bet all three of my points now
I'm a low-power kind of spin guy. Just the just the casual
just just give it a little spin a little spin a roo and
I
Got a point. Oh
I'm currently in second place Paul. I must wager it all dick
Wager it all. Hi Jacob. Oh, here we go. I
Think he was just commenting on my attitude
No, no, no, you don't you son of a fuck
My cruise and scoop Matt wins with six points Jacob is in second place with four points
Paul is in third place with three points
Those are the official scores and the scores before the bonus round don't matter at all
That's from cruise and scoop
It's a price is right if you want to send us a price is right or an obelisk jock versus nerd or a scooperty or an
Old-school jock versus nerd or some scoop mail send us all the things over there at hey scoops comm go over to hey scoops comm
Right there on the home page do all those things. It'll be great. I promise you won't regret it
I want to thank let's see people here, right? No, no, not yet. Not yet. I don't know why I said that so excitedly like
Don't look for people's names yet. Guess we don't have names yet. Thank you
I want to thank
Chris for sending in it that price is right. Yes. Yes, and for making me look like an amateur to my crucial magician my group agent
I heard the rooms going away
No more boats I
Heard boats don't float anymore
Stop floating. Oh, no
Say it ain't so submarines
They're poorly designed submarines. These are
Norma this time we thank people who support support our patreon this podcast will be possible without patreon support
absolutely among the numerous benefits as you get notifications and links for our
Live episode recordings that we're doing on twitch as we hunt for a new churn. I was missing the churn
yesterday, I was feeling like you know, just
It kind of set my week where I would I do miss the churn driving to the churn and going home
Kind of yeah, help me really keep like a mental calendar in my head. Yeah of like what's going on Paul
You moved to Pittsburgh. You can't meh me you know, I said I said no I said yeah, I was agree
I was a yeah, not a man. Yeah
No, I was nodding my head. Yes, uh, let the record show I agree I
Know I'm ending the record to a decide that Paul was nodding his head
Thank you. No, I got down here to my little uh, my little mini churn and it's very
It's very reminiscent of the churn honestly with all the tchotchkes that I have around here, right? Oh, yeah everywhere
You look there's there's stuff scattered everywhere. So it I've recreated the churn to the best of my ability
Yeah, that's what I need. I need a better physical churn space, but we don't have any so that'll be well
You've got two kids that makes it hard. That's it. That's it. And the answer is move out
But I could do it very easily, but then that means my life is sad
No life's gonna be so much fun when the kids are gone and this is all you have left in your life
All right, Matt. We're gonna do a test right now. Yeah, and everybody at home with kids
You can play along with this test. I want you to think right now
It's right if you have young young children that still live with you. You can play along with this test Matt
I want you to think about these two scenarios
The first scenario is the one that you just mentioned your children have left home. They have they have gone
They have spread their wings. They no longer live with you now, then here's a second scenario
They're both 34 years old and still live with you
I bet I bet it'd be one of those really like delightful like dysfunctional parents for like I don't want to talk about it
Like like other parents are back your kids still at home, and I think
I think you're gonna be okay cuz I think that's gonna happen to a lot more people as time goes forward here
I do the show
Said I said we do for living. She goes arm retired. I said, oh
Millennials put your fingers in your ears. Don't listen
No, and so yeah anyhow we get all that because people find it find the time to head on over to preaching fun comm
It's like a tear that works for them today. Yes
Or if Matt's kids are gonna live with you head on over to farts in a bag dot-biz
That's farts in a bag dot-biz that along with preaching fun calm it takes you to our patreon page
We're for as little as two three three
You can help keep this show on the air it's like Matt said this show is not possible without patreon support
So please head over to preaching fun comm farts in a bag dot-biz
You put a little change in the bucket there and keep this show going. We've been doing it for 12 plus years
We don't have any sign of stopping anytime soon. No, whether you'll want us to or not
The British Bulldogs gonna win whether he wants to or not. I
And of course, you know, we converted our
Our our scoop fest to robe time, right our scoop fest. Yeah, it's a robe time
And that's because some people buy different really cool shirts of ours to wear during the scoop events
and so if you want to wear a really cool shirt underneath your
New robe that's coming out of the scoop fest. You can head on over to
store jingle dot-com. Oh
That's true. I'm sorry. I didn't know where you were going. I didn't have store jingling
For people watching the the the twitch here I am NOT wearing a new robe I'm wearing I'm wearing a nice old robe
I'm wearing my oh, there's the camera. I'm wearing my old Tropicana. Oh, no, we've not revealed the robes yet
No, no, or the secret. There will be road
Yeah, there will be robes, but it's it's a thing. Yeah, there's oh, there's other stuff. It's gonna be great
It's gonna be so good to do fest. I want it. I want to say in advance. I'll say this again
Kudos to Matt and Jacob for all the legwork
Always, you know, no, seriously, it really does. I really do appreciate it Jacob. Yes, let's go
I really do appreciate all that you guys are doing out there in the location
I've done little bits here and there nothing like what you guys are getting done. So I really really appreciate it
But it's gonna be magic for you. I reach out to perform for the variety show. Yeah
Some we haven't noticed that I'm just like there's some of we've we have you and I have brought up Paul that we've forgotten to
Include in the past. I was like, I'm not gonna forget this year wrote it down wrote the person saying do you want to do?
A bit in our variety show. Yeah, and he wrote. Oh, I don't I don't do my act for that kind of money, but thank you
And I was like I respect it. I respect. Yeah. Yeah sure. I'm always fine with a no I know I'm relieved
That I no longer feel guilt for having not included this person in the past and yeah
Now also go like I respect you just saying straight up like oh, no, I promise
That's totally fine. Yeah, that's totally fine. Now. I will I would are coming to see Chris angel perform
He won't be performing who will not I I would argue but you're gonna tell me that he invented scoop fest before we did
hilarious
Clearly, which is true. Whoever this is and I'm not clear on that, but whoever this is
Is not aware of the community and is not aware of what scoop fest really is
Well, that's that's I've made this mistake before with reaching out to people who I thought I was closer to than I was and then
Understanding our podcast and going like what?
No, thank you. Right, right, right. Oh, I'm sorry. You don't understand the you don't know what's going on
I don't know what this is gonna be no one has ever no one has ever regretted doing scoop
No, I was gonna say to to a to a man everyone that has performed and come to our our spot has been
Gracious and not only have people never regretted doing scoop fest
performing at scoop fest they they have people have come to me after scoop fest is over with people who were set to perform and
Yeah, like they didn't get to perform for whatever reason and then they have been mad for years
Always they're like hey, when are you doing that scoop fest again? We got it. We got a set of times. Yeah
All right. We're still here. So let's wrap this up. Thank you all so much
Yes
Can't wait
Corner baby
Reaching mine